حسنًا ، هذا نص من خمس صفحات
، يبدو أنه
نسخة مكتملة تقريبًا من مكالمة يوليو ،
حيث طلب الرئيس ترامب من
الرئيس الأوكراني سولينسكي عدة
مرات التعاون مع المدعي
العام بار ومحاميه رودي
جولياني محاميه الخاص للنظر
في قضية بايدن ومحاميه.  صياد الابن
ويجب أن نلاحظ أن الرئيس سزالينسكي
ذكر التواصل مع جولياني أولاً
مرة أخرى ، إنه خمس صفحات كان هذا في الصفحة
الرابعة حيث تم طرح برايدن الآن
بعد تبادل المجاملات.
بالنسبة لأوكرانيا مقارنة
بالدول الأوروبية الآن ، فهو
لا يذكر المساعدة العسكرية على وجه التحديد ، لكنه
يقول إن أسعار الولايات المتحدة
جيدة جدًا لأوكرانيا ، لذا لم يكن ذلك بمثابة مقايضة صريحة ،
لكن من الواضح أن الرئيس كان
يلقي بطلباته إلى أوكرانيا
بعد هذا التبادل.  حول مساعدة الولايات المتحدة
لأوكرانيا يقول ترامب الفنلندي إنني أود منك
أن تقدم لنا معروفًا
سأله يو  كيرين للنظر في دورها
في انتخابات عام 2016 حيث ادعى
دون دليل على أن أوكرانيا لديها
خادم DNC ، وفي بايدن
ذكر بايدن في الصفحة الرابعة ، قال إن
هناك الكثير من الحديث عن بايدن
وابنه والكثير من الناس يريدون ذلك
اكتشف ما إذا كان بايدن قد أوقف مقاضاة
شركة مرتبطة بابنه ، يجب أن
نلاحظ أنه لا يوجد دليل مباشر
لدعم هذا الادعاء بأن
الرئيس قد أدلى به في المكالمة وقال لا سزالينسكي
ردًا على الرئيس الذي
طرح بايدن أن
المدعي العام القادم سوف  انظر إليه الآن ،
يجب أن نلاحظ أنه يوجد في أسفل هذا
السجل إخلاء مسؤولية يفيد بأن هذا
ليس اقتباسًا لنسخة نصية حرفيًا للطعم
للمناقشة ، حيث يشير
إلى أن نص هذا المستند يسجل
الملاحظات وتذكرات
الموقف-  ضباط مناوبة غرفة أحد موظفي سياسة مجلس الأمن القومي
المكلفين بالاستماع
وإحياء ذكرى المحادثة واستمارة مكتوبة
أثناء إجراء المحادثات ،
أريد أن أشير إلى مسؤول كبير في البيت الأبيض
يقول إن  هناك
برنامج للتعرف على الصوت يضع
النص ما يسميه
نسخة ثم يقوم أولئك الذين
سيستمعون إلى المكالمة الهاتفية بفحصها
للتأكد من أنها قراءة دقيقة